It says, there's a comment, slash slash, we must prepare for his coming. Everything's lowercase except for the H and his. And then struct goeser. And it's a function object that calls something's destructor. Well, the comment made more sense because I think that used to be a forward declaration. So obviously this is a Ghostbusters reference. Welcome to ADSB the podcast episode 242 recorded on May 21st, 2025. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we finish part four of our four-part conversation with Jared Hoverock.
上面写着，有一条注释，斜杠斜杠，我们必须为他的降临做好准备。除了 H 和 his 之外，所有字母都是小写。然后是 struct goeser。这是一个调用某物析构函数的函数对象。嗯，这条注释更有意义，因为我认为它曾经是一个前向声明。所以很明显，这是一个《捉鬼敢死队》的梗。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 242 期，录制于 2025 年 5 月 21 日。我是 Connor，今天和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起，我们完成了与 Jared Hoverock 四部分对话的第四部分。
We chat about thrust, parallel algorithms and more. That actually kind of leads to another question that I had meant to ask earlier, which is you talked a little bit about the transfer of Thrust from research to production in the handoff, but that was sort of after Thrust had sort of made it. At the time, there were a couple other libraries that were kind of similar to Thrust, like CUDPP. And I think there was one or two other ones. And I just wonder, can you tell us a little bit about when you guys first put Thrust out there?
我们聊了 Thrust、并行算法等等。这其实引出了我之前想问的另一个问题，那就是你刚才谈到 Thrust 从研究到生产的移交过程，但那是在 Thrust 已经取得成功之后。当时还有其他几个类似于 Thrust 的库，比如 CUDPP。我想还有一两个其他的。我很好奇，你能跟我们聊聊你们最初发布 Thrust 的时候吗？
What was the response? Did it just very rapidly get a lot of adoption and growing popularity? And like, what, why was it that Thrust is the one that succeeded and became so ubiquitous? And like, how quickly did that happen? I mean, the reason it succeeded is because we chose the right interface. How fast it happened, um, I don't really remember. I remember we gave, uh, at the first GTC, we gave like two talks on Thrust, and I remember the crowd being large and enthusiastic. Um, so it at least had succeeded enough to attract some, you know, some people to a talk.
当时的反应如何？它是否很快就获得了广泛的采用并日益流行？还有，为什么 Thrust 成功了并变得如此普及？这发生得有多快？嗯，它之所以成功，是因为我们选择了正确的接口。至于发生得有多快，嗯，我不太记得了。我记得在第一届 GTC 大会上，我们做了两场关于 Thrust 的演讲，我记得观众很多，而且非常热情。所以它至少已经成功到足以吸引一些人来听演讲了。
Do you have the slides from those talks? Somewhere they might be in. Are they not in the repository? They might not be. I don't know. Oh, I don't think so. They're probably in Perfor somewhere. If you look through Perfor, you'll find them.
你有那些演讲的幻灯片吗？它们可能在某个地方。它们不在代码库里吗？可能不在。我不知道。哦，我觉得不在。它们可能在 Perforce 的某个地方。如果你在 Perforce 里找找，应该能找到。
Um, or I might have them in a Google drive or something like that. Anyway. Yeah. They were, Nathan gave a talk and I gave a talk at the GTC and Nathan's talk was sort of here's what thrust is and I think my talk was like here to do, here's how to do some, you know, interesting tricks with thrust and it's just, you know, walk, the slides just walk through some of the example programs. But, so how long, so like after that, did you ever reach a point where you guys were just like swamped with PRs and like, when did you, when did it become like visible to you that there were a lot of people using this? And when did the writing on the wall that it was going to have to be taken over by the
嗯，或者我可能把它们存在 Google Drive 之类的地方。总之，是的。Nathan 做了一场演讲，我也在 GTC 上做了一场。Nathan 的演讲大概是介绍 Thrust 是什么，而我的演讲大概是关于如何用 Thrust 做一些有趣的技巧，幻灯片里就是演示了一些示例程序。那么，在那之后，你们有没有达到一种被 PR 淹没的程度？你们是什么时候意识到有很多人在使用它的？什么时候意识到它必须被工程团队接管的？
engineering team? It never became visible to me that a lot of people were using it. I would have been happy to... Nathan was really pro-productization because for career reasons, I would have rather not productize it so we could continue, you know, developing it in interesting directions, I guess. I guess the problem is when it got productized, it became less flexible, like changing it became harder. You know, before we actually released it on Google code, like GitHub didn't even exist at the time. So we're the
我从来没有感觉到有很多人在使用它。我本来会很高兴……Nathan 非常支持产品化，因为出于职业发展的考虑，我宁愿不把它产品化，这样我们就可以继续在有趣的方向上开发它。我想问题在于，当它被产品化后，它变得不那么灵活了，比如修改它变得更难了。你知道，在我们真正把它发布到 Google Code 上之前，那时甚至还没有 GitHub。所以我们最初是在 Google Code 上发布的。如果我们想改变什么，我们就会直接改。如果人们发现了 bug，我们就会修复它。第二天就能搞定之类的。你不能对一个产品这样做。但我知道，听到你们谈论它，或者听到你们谈论外面的人在使用它，我才意识到它有很多用户。当时它看起来就像一个我们正在从事的、乐于从事的项目。是的，我一直有那种感觉。而且，我想对于身处研究领域的人来说，这很难，因为你做了一个东西，如果它稍微成功了一点，它就会被某个工程团队接手，然后你就去研究下一个东西了，你不一定会看到……我觉得现在情况不同了。所以 Thrust 是 NVIDIA 研究部门最早产品化的项目之一。我们当时在向产品团队移交项目方面没有太多经验。
initial releases on Google code. And if we wanted to change something, we would just change something. And if people had a bug, we would fix it. You know, next day or something like that. You can't really do that with a product. But I know like hearing you guys talk about it or hearing you guys talk about people out in the wild using it I guess is when it dawned on me that it has a lot of users. Like at the time it just seemed like a you know a project we were working on and we're happy to work on. Yeah I was I was I was, I sort of always had that sense. And I mean, I guess it's, it's hard for folks who sit in research because you, you produce
所以我认为如果这件事发生在今天，研究人员可以参与到产品中，只要他们感兴趣。但在那个年代，这被视为“好吧，你们把这个东西产品化了，是时候去研究新东西了”。但我认为从那以后，人们可能看到了让原始作者保持参与的价值，如果他们愿意的话，在最近的项目中可能会多一些。你为 Thrust 感到自豪吗？
a thing and then if it becomes marginally successful, then it gets picked up by, you know, some engineering team and you then you go work on the next thing and you don't necessarily see what the... I think it works differently now. So Thrust was one of the first things that NV research productized. And we didn't have a lot of experience with handing off things to product teams.
一件事情，如果它稍微取得了一点成功，就会被某个工程团队接手，然后你就去忙下一件事了，你不一定会看到……我觉得现在情况不同了。Thrust 是英伟达研究部门最早产品化的项目之一。当时我们对于如何将项目移交给产品团队并没有太多经验。
So I think if it were to happen today, researchers could be involved in the product, like to the extent that they're interested in. But in those days, it was sort of seen as like, okay, you guys productize this thing, it's time to work on something new. But I think since then, people probably see the value of keeping the original authors sort of in the loop, maybe a bit more if they want to be with more recent projects. Are you proud of Thrust?
所以我觉得如果这件事发生在今天，研究人员可以根据自己的兴趣参与到产品中。但在当时，大家觉得既然你们已经把这个东西产品化了，那就该去研究新东西了。不过我想从那以后，人们可能意识到让原始作者保持参与是有价值的，如果他们愿意的话，在最近的项目中参与度可能会更高。你为 Thrust 感到自豪吗？
I have mixed feelings about it. I guess what I see is the sort of missed opportunities. And I sort of see the mistakes that could be corrected or should have been corrected. But it's gratifying to see that people still like to use it and think it's worthwhile. But it's hard not to focus on things you wish could have been done better. One frequent thing that gets brought up is, well, thrust is great for many things and it's a great place to start. If you're doing, if your algorithm ends up being one call, it's a single pass
我对此心情复杂。我看到的是一些错失的机会，以及那些本可以或应该被纠正的错误。但看到人们仍然喜欢使用它并认为它有价值，这让我感到欣慰。不过，很难不去关注那些你希望做得更好的地方。一个经常被提及的问题是，Thrust 在很多方面都很棒，是一个很好的起点。如果你的算法最终只是一个调用，是一个单次传递
thing, thrust is perfect for that. If you're launching multiple things because thrust doesn't have any synchrony model because it blocks, it can become a performance bottleneck. That's something that is an often cited criticism of thrust. And we sometimes think of it as being an on-ramp for parallelism that it's easy and gets people started, but oftentimes if you need to architect a much more complex application where you're launching a bunch of different kernels, then you have to go and do something a little bit lower level. And had Thrust evolved earlier and more to support asynchronous in a more structured way, perhaps it could have been even more successful than it is today.
的东西，Thrust 是完美的。但如果你要启动多个任务，因为 Thrust 没有同步模型，它是阻塞的，这可能会成为性能瓶颈。这是 Thrust 经常被诟病的一点。我们有时把它看作是并行计算的入门工具，它很容易上手，但如果你需要构建一个更复杂的应用程序，需要启动一堆不同的内核，那么你就必须去使用更底层的东西。如果 Thrust 能更早地演进，以更结构化的方式支持异步，也许它会比今天更成功。
Oh, for sure. And Thrust predates Asynchrony in CUDA. Thrust predates CUDA Streams, right? And it was always not clear how to make it work well with CUDA Streams, and I don't think it ever really did, or does it work well with kuda streams and I don't think it ever really did or does work well with kuda streams. I guess another regret is that in addition to thrust, we also have cub and these two things are interdependencies like there's cyclic dependencies between the two libraries which causes problems. I guess it's just a shame that we couldn't find a way to do cub-like things in Thrust and, or you know, thrust-like
哦，肯定的。Thrust 的出现早于 CUDA 的异步机制。Thrust 早于 CUDA Streams，对吧？而且一直不清楚如何让它与 CUDA Streams 很好地配合，我不认为它曾经或者现在能很好地与 CUDA Streams 配合。我想另一个遗憾是，除了 Thrust，我们还有 CUB，这两个库之间存在相互依赖，即库之间存在循环依赖，这导致了问题。我觉得很遗憾，我们没能找到一种方法在 Thrust 中实现类似 CUB 的功能，或者说在 CUB 中实现类似 Thrust 的功能。
things in Cub. It's sort of an awkward situation to have both libraries. Well, and it's actually interesting that you mentioned that because, you know, we – so when I started at NVIDIA in 2017, I was – Thrust had been essentially without a maintainer for like two or three years. And like on day – well, I didn't even know what I was being hired to do when I started. Like it was unclear from the job description. But – and like my hiring was weird, but just like Olivier had talked to someone and been like, hey,
同时拥有这两个库确实有点尴尬。嗯，你提到这一点很有趣，因为当我 2017 年加入英伟达时，Thrust 基本上已经有两三年没有维护者了。而且在第一天……我刚开始工作时甚至不知道自己被雇来做什么。职位描述里写得不清楚。我的招聘过程很奇怪，就像 Olivier 和某人谈过，说，嘿，
you should interview this guy. And then I interviewed. And then they're like, oh, you want a job. And they gave me an offer. And then I showed up. And on day one, they're like, so here's this thing, Thrust. You're now in charge of it. There's no product manager.
你应该面试一下这个人。然后我面试了。接着他们说，哦，你想要这份工作。他们给了我一个录用通知。然后我就去上班了。第一天，他们说，这是 Thrust，现在归你负责了。没有产品经理。
Nobody's really touched it in two years. Figure out what to do with it. And so then I started the CUDA C++ core libraries team at Nvidia and originally it was just me and then it was me and one other person for some period of time and we productized CUB just as Thrust had been productized and did some amount of work to unify things between
两年没人碰过它了。你自己想办法处理吧。于是我启动了英伟达的 CUDA C++ 核心库团队，起初只有我一个人，后来有一段时间是我和另外一个人，我们把 CUB 产品化了，就像之前把 Thrust 产品化一样，并做了一些工作来统一两者。
the two. But now, you know, eight years later, that team, the CUDA C++ Core Libraries team, or I think it's now just the Core Compute Libraries team, same acronym but different meaning, it's now like a, I don't know, it's more than 10 people team. It could be 15 people or so. It's a lot of people working on it and they work on Thrust, Cub, and libcu++, which is our port of libc++. And there's a move for all three of these libraries to essentially merge together into
但现在，八年过去了，那个团队，CUDA C++ 核心库团队，或者我想现在叫核心计算库团队，缩写一样但含义不同，现在已经是一个拥有超过 10 人的团队了。可能有 15 人左右。很多人在上面工作，他们负责 Thrust、CUB 和 libcu++（我们对 libc++ 的移植）。这三个库目前都在向合并为一个统一的东西发展。
one unified thing. And they're all in now a monorepo now. In fact, there's some talk about not the thrust name, thrust name will essentially always exist because there's so many people who have written code for it. But of migrating the thrust back end and merging it with some of the other things. So the thrust code base, parts of the thrust code base that have been around for a long time now essentially going away in the future.
它们现在都在一个单体仓库里。事实上，有人在讨论不再使用 Thrust 这个名字，Thrust 这个名字基本上会一直存在，因为有太多人写过相关的代码。但正在讨论迁移 Thrust 后端并将其与其他东西合并。所以 Thrust 代码库中存在了很长时间的部分，未来基本上会消失。
And all of these things merging together into a more unified structure down the road. I think the last thing I would ask you about is the thrust was open source sort of from the start and what was that like? I mean, this was in a very early time. It was before GitHub. You mentioned it was like Google code. But how did you collaborate with people back in the day? How did users find you? How did you interact?
所有这些东西最终都会合并成一个更统一的结构。我想问你的最后一个问题是，Thrust 从一开始就是开源的，那是什么样的体验？我的意思是，那是在非常早期的时代。那是在 GitHub 之前。你提到过像 Google Code。但当时你是如何与人们合作的？用户是如何找到你的？你是如何互动的？
What was that like? We had a Google Groups mailing list that people would ask, how do I do this in Thrust? That sort of thing. Or maybe they wouldn't report bugs. There wasn't like use Discord or Slack or anything like that. Um, so just through, um, you know, mailing lists, I guess that's how people used to collaborate in the 2000s, you know, through a mailing list or something like that. I remember when we, uh, push the code for the first time, we, we
那是什么样的？我们有一个 Google Groups 邮件列表，人们会在上面问，我该如何在 Thrust 中做这个？诸如此类。或者他们会报告错误。当时没有 Discord 或 Slack 之类的东西。所以只是通过……你知道，邮件列表，我想这就是 2000 年代人们协作的方式，通过邮件列表之类的东西。我记得当我们第一次发布代码时，我们
announced it on Hacker News and some subreddit and just, you know, waiting to see what would happen. But as far as I know, Thrust was the first open source thing that NVIDIA ever published. I don't know of any that are, there might be a few previous publications, but I don't know of them. So that was, you know, we had to get special permission for that. You are in fact correct that Thrust was in fact the first open source project at Nvidia. And we know this because Thrust completely predated any open source process at Nvidia. And every year or two, somebody's like,
在 Hacker News 和一些 subreddit 上宣布了它，然后就等着看会发生什么。但据我所知，Thrust 是英伟达发布过的第一个开源项目。我不确定之前是否有过其他发布，但我不知道。所以我们必须为此获得特别许可。你确实说对了，Thrust 确实是英伟达的第一个开源项目。我们知道这一点是因为 Thrust 的出现完全早于英伟达的任何开源流程。每隔一两年，就会有人问，
hey, why isn't there an entry in our listing of open source things in this database for Thrust? And we're like, well, because it was the first one. It existed before all these things. Yeah, well, just the nature of the software demanded that the code be available, right? Because it's C++ templates. So there's no way to hide it and there's no way to use it unless you have the source. So, had to be open source. Yeah.
嘿，为什么我们的开源项目列表中没有 Thrust？我们回答说，嗯，因为它是第一个。它在所有这些流程之前就存在了。是的，软件的性质要求代码必须公开，对吧？因为它是 C++ 模板。所以除非你有源代码，否则无法隐藏它，也无法使用它。所以，它必须是开源的。是的。
And I mean, you mentioned that Thrust lifted from other projects. And in fact, Thrust contains, you know, Thrust Iterator code was just taken from Boost and some other parts were taken from some other places. And it probably would have not evolved as quickly if you had not been able to pull in all this other stuff. That's right. Yeah. I'm not a
我的意思是，你提到 Thrust 借鉴了其他项目。事实上，Thrust 包含……你知道，Thrust 的迭代器代码就是直接从 Boost 拿来的，其他一些部分是从其他地方拿来的。如果当时不能引入所有这些东西，它可能不会发展得这么快。没错。是的。我不是一个
expert GPU programmer. I can just kind of get by, but I'm good at taking other people's code and making sense of it. So that's mostly what we did. Jared, if you're not an expert GPU programmer, I don't know what we are. There are levels. There are levels and yeah. What does that mean for us, Jared? What does that mean for the people? Well, the whole idea of Thrust is that you don't have to be
专业的 GPU 程序员。我只能勉强应付，但我擅长拿别人的代码并理解它。所以我们大部分时间都在做这个。Jared，如果你不是专业的 GPU 程序员，我不知道我们算什么。这有等级之分。确实有等级之分。这对我们意味着什么，Jared？这对大家意味着什么？嗯，Thrust 的整个理念就是你不需要成为
an expert programmer to use a GPU. You just take something off the shelf. Someone else is already figured that out. It's really the... what was the Comrad tagline? The original Comrad tagline. Own the means of computation. It was actually very fitting. When I worked on the HBX project, the original name for the programming model that Thomas
一名专家程序员就能使用 GPU。你只需要拿现成的东西用。别人已经搞定了。这真的是……Comrad 的标语是什么？最初的 Comrad 标语。拥有计算手段。这其实非常贴切。当我从事 HBX 项目时，Thomas Sterling 想要使用的编程模型的最初名称是
Sterling wanted to use was, he wanted to call it Agincourt for the Battle of Agincourt which was a, I don't know what century battle between the British and the French. The French had an army that was primarily mounted knights and the English army was primarily peasant longbowmen and they defeated the nobility. So Thomas Sterling had this very idyllic story of this. It was this programming model where tons of tiny little cores and tiny little tasks would take over and topple the great evil that
Agincourt，为了纪念阿金库尔战役，那是一场……我不记得是哪个世纪的战役，发生在英国人和法国人之间。法国军队主要是骑马的骑士，而英国军队主要是农民长弓手，他们击败了贵族。所以 Thomas Sterling 有一个关于这个的非常田园诗般的故事。这是一个编程模型，大量的微小核心和微小的任务将接管并推翻那个邪恶的
was MPI and sort of synchronous message passing program models. There was, you know, I couldn't find it. I tried to ask Jatch GPT to search for it while we were chatting, but there were a couple interesting snippets of code from like the early days of Thrust that had some quirky comments that if I ever come across again,
MPI 和同步消息传递编程模型。我找不到它。我们在聊天时我试着让 ChatGPT 搜索它，但早期 Thrust 的代码中有一些有趣的片段，里面有一些古怪的注释，如果我再遇到它们，
we'll have to have you back on to ask you to explain. What are you thinking of? It was like something like Frobenator or something like that. There was some weirdly named class somewhere, and then there were a couple of them. I think I know what you're talking about. You're talking about Gozer?
我们得请你回来解释一下。你在想什么？就像 Frobenator 之类的东西。某个地方有一个命名很奇怪的类，而且不止一个。我想我知道你在说什么。你在说 Gozer 吗？
Yes. I am talking about Gozer. What about Gozer? Yes! I am talking about Gozer! What was Gozer? Is the code still there or is it gone? I'm looking right now. I really... If they deleted that, I'm gonna have some choice words. Oh no, I think it's gone! How did you spell it? Was it 1-0 or 2-0s?
是的。我在说 Gozer。Gozer 怎么了？是的！我在说 Gozer！Gozer 是什么？代码还在吗，还是已经没了？我正在看。我真的……如果他们删了那个，我会说些难听的话。哦不，我想它没了！你是怎么拼写的？是一个 O 还是两个 O？
Gozer is spelled G-O-Z-G-R. One O or two O's. Gozer is spelled G-O-Z-E-R. Yeah. Ha ha ha ha. I'm sure it's in the GitHub history somewhere. It's still here. So could you explain yourself? It says, I'm going to read this.
Gozer 的拼写是 G-O-Z-G-R。一个 O 还是两个 O？Gozer 的拼写是 G-O-Z-E-R。是的。哈哈哈哈。我肯定它在 GitHub 的历史记录里的某个地方。它还在。那么你能解释一下自己吗？上面写着，我要读一下。
I think it's pretty. It says, there's a comment, slash slash, we must prepare for his coming. Everything's lowercase except for the H in his. And then struct goeser. And it's a function object that calls something's destructor. Well, the comment made more sense, because I think that used to be a forward declaration. So obviously this is a Ghostbusters reference.
我觉得它很有趣。上面有一条注释，斜杠斜杠，我们必须为他的到来做准备。除了 his 中的 H，其他都是小写。然后是 struct goeser。它是一个调用某物析构函数的函数对象。嗯，注释更有意义了，因为我想那曾经是一个前向声明。所以这显然是一个《捉鬼敢死队》的引用。
Oh man. Obviously I was born in 1990. I don't know what this means. Ghosts are the destructor is the reference. So this is a functor that calls a destructor. I remember I got an email a long time ago. I never thought anyone would see this. I just thought it was being funny.
天哪。显然我出生于 1990 年。我不知道这是什么意思。Ghosts 是析构函数，这是引用。所以这是一个调用析构函数的仿函数。我记得很久以前我收到过一封邮件。我从没想过会有人看到这个。我只是觉得这很有趣。
But I got an email from a compiler engineer at Nvidia because, I don't know, something about Thrust was exposing a compiler bug and it involved this destruct that we're looking at here. And JD like posts the refro in the email and he's got Gozer staring back at me and I'm like... We didn't discuss the name or... I never thought this would The real question is, Bryce, did you know what this meant? I had no idea. I am, I like you. I'm the same age as you, Connor. I mean you're one year, you're one year younger? Older, younger? What year were you born, Connor? I'm 90. You're 80. You're 91, right? Yeah. 91. Yeah, you're one year younger. I was gonna say I would feel very bad about myself if you understood the reference and I did not.
但我收到了一封来自英伟达编译器工程师的邮件，因为，不知道为什么，Thrust 的某些东西暴露了一个编译器错误，它涉及我们在这里看到的这个析构函数。JD 在邮件里贴出了引用，Gozer 盯着我看，我当时就……我们没有讨论过这个名字，或者……我从没想过这会……真正的问题是，Bryce，你知道这是什么意思吗？我完全不知道。我像你一样。我和你同龄，Connor。我的意思是，你比我小一岁？大一岁，小一岁？你哪年出生的，Connor？我是 90 年的。你是 80 年的。你是 91 年的，对吧？是的。91 年。是的，你比我小一岁。我本来想说，如果你理解这个梗而我不理解，我会对自己感到非常糟糕。
I read this and I was like, I don't understand the joke, but here we are. I don't know how many people we have listening. I think over time it'll roughly be three or 4,000, so I mean. It is, it is line 102 in thrust slash detail slash allocator slash destroy range dot i n l. I'm sure you've got some boomers in your audience. Jared, were these, I've always wondered this, so I'll ask even though we're over time, but why not.
我读了这段代码，当时想，我不明白这个笑话，但事实就是这样。我不知道我们有多少听众。我想随着时间的推移，大概会有三四千人，所以我的意思是。它在 thrust/detail/allocator/destroy_range.inl 的第 102 行。我敢肯定你的听众里有一些婴儿潮一代。Jared，这些……我一直很好奇，所以我即使超时了也要问，为什么不呢。
Two things I'll ask. One, thrust has a a lot of these headers that are.INL, like inline. Was this because you at some point had people that would include these in their.cpp files and you wanted to separate them from the declarations? Or was there at some point a version of Thrust that had a mode where you just like boost ASEA where you could build like a library version of it in addition to the header only
我要问两件事。第一，Thrust 有很多这种 .INL 后缀的头文件，比如 inline。这是因为你在某个时候有人会把这些包含在他们的 .cpp 文件中，而你想把它们从声明中分离出来吗？还是说曾经有一个版本的 Thrust 有一种模式，你可以像 Boost ASIO 那样，除了头文件版本之外，还可以构建一个库版本？
version or like what is what is that dot I and L like naming convention mean? I think that's just a jaredism. I don't remember why I chose to do that. The other question is, Thrust uses.h for its header files and some other CUDA projects use.cuh and some other extensions. Why.h? Why not.cuh? Why not make up your own extension?
或者那个 .INL 命名约定是什么意思？我想那只是 Jared 的个人习惯。我不记得为什么选择那样做。另一个问题是，Thrust 使用 .h 作为头文件，而其他一些 CUDA 项目使用 .cuh 和其他扩展名。为什么是 .h？为什么不是 .cuh？为什么不编造你自己的扩展名？
.coo? I've always thought that... I've always disliked.coo. C-U-H. But at least at some point there was a goal that you could include any thrust editor with a normal C++ compiler and it wouldn't freak out. And I don't know if that's still the case, but there wasn't, you don't, you didn't have to include it with MVCC. So it seemed unnecessary to. That's actually, it's a good point that we didn't talk about this, but Thrust has this backend system that we mentioned, but we didn't talk specifically about the fact that Thrust can target CPUs, it can target CPU parallelism. And it's designed in a way where no part of the Thrust interface says CUDA.
.coo？我一直认为……我一直很讨厌 .coo。C-U-H。但至少在某个时候，有一个目标是你可以用普通的 C++ 编译器包含任何 Thrust 头文件，它不会崩溃。我不知道现在是否还是这样，但你不需要用 NVCC 来包含它。所以 .h 似乎没必要改。这其实是一个很好的点，我们没谈过这个，但 Thrust 有我们提到的后端系统，但我们没有具体谈论 Thrust 可以针对 CPU，它可以针对 CPU 并行。它的设计方式使得 Thrust 接口的任何部分都没有提到 CUDA。
And Thrust has this, it uses the host and device terminology, where it's very abstract from the GPU. You can have a device back in, it's not a GPU back in. Was that intended to help adoption? Why do that? Because it seems like it created a bunch of work too. Because it was helpful when just debugging your program for correctness to be able to use like a sequential backend or, I don't know, like open MP backend, for example. So I think it definitely helped with adoption.
Thrust 使用了 host 和 device 的术语，它与 GPU 非常抽象。你可以有一个 device 后端，它不一定是 GPU 后端。那是为了帮助推广吗？为什么要这样做？因为这似乎也创造了很多工作。因为在调试程序的正确性时，能够使用像顺序后端或 Open MP 后端这样的东西是很有帮助的。所以我认为它绝对有助于推广。
Just getting the CUDA stuff right in your CUDA C++ program is like a task on its own. And really, if you wanted to, you could write everything. Just get your algorithms skeletoned together first, making sure that it works in parallel before actually targeting a CUDA GPU for real. I mean, you could totally – I could totally see that being helpful to people. Like going all in on GPU parallelism from the get go is often a big, big first step. So it's helpful to face things sometimes. And I think the CPU back ends can help with that.
在你的CUDA C++程序中把CUDA相关的东西搞定本身就是一项任务。说实话，如果你愿意，你可以把所有东西都写出来。先把你算法的骨架搭好，确保它在并行环境下能运行，然后再真正针对CUDA GPU进行开发。我的意思是，你完全可以——我完全能看出这对大家很有帮助。从一开始就全力投入GPU并行化通常是迈出的重要第一步。所以有时面对这些问题很有帮助。我认为CPU后端可以在这方面提供帮助。
What was debugging like in the early days? Well, we used to have device emulation in CUDA. So MVCC used to have a CPU backend. You could put it into a mode where it would generate x86 code, and you could actually step through your code in a debugger. So that's what debugging was like in the early days. But then they phased that out very soon.
早期的调试是什么样的？嗯，我们过去在CUDA中有设备仿真。所以MVCC过去有一个CPU后端。你可以把它设置为一种模式，让它生成x86代码，然后你就可以在调试器中逐步执行你的代码。这就是早期调试的样子。但后来他们很快就淘汰了这种模式。
They used to use an entirely different compiler back end for MVCC. Open 64. Yes, is what they use. Anyway, I think maybe that made that device simulation mode easier. But I don't know, I've never used the buggers I've always used print after bugging so that's what it was like for me Connor has some thoughts you've always used print after bugging you've never used debuggers I used when I used to use Microsoft IDE I used to have a you know a pretty good debugger and I would use it then. But no, these days I don't use an IDE.
他们过去在MVCC中使用了一个完全不同的编译器后端，Open 64。是的，就是他们用的那个。总之，我觉得这可能让设备仿真模式更容易实现。但我不知道，我从没用过调试器，我一直用打印调试，所以对我来说就是这样。Connor有一些想法，你一直用打印调试，从没用过调试器？我以前用微软IDE的时候，确实有一个相当不错的调试器，我那时会用它。但现在，我不使用IDE。
I use printf and the terminal to program. I also use printf. Is that because you watched the last of us season one episode four where it was survivalist technology and you really identified with that and you wanted to be like modern technology is not for me and I'm going to bunker down. There used to be this guy at Nvidia, I think he was a dev tech, he had a blog, but he was an actual survivalist. He wouldn't use Lib C.
我用printf和终端来编程。我也用printf。这是因为你看了《最后生还者》第一季第四集，里面讲的是生存主义技术，你对此产生了共鸣，觉得现代技术不适合你，你想躲进地堡里吗？Nvidia曾经有个人，我想他是开发技术人员，他有个博客，但他是个真正的生存主义者。他甚至不用Lib C。
He wouldn't use any headers at all like he would just insert system calls if he wanted to print into his program I guess because it made his programs fat I'm not actually sure why but one thing is he made you know compiling and linking is his program very. But if he needed to debug, I think he would put S to the screen, and he would put S from a syscall or something like that. So there's levels to survivalism, too. So you're saying you're not even close to what
他根本不用任何头文件，如果想在程序里打印东西，他会直接插入系统调用，我猜是因为这会让他的程序变臃肿，我不确定具体原因，但有一点是他让程序的编译和链接变得非常……但如果他需要调试，我想他会把东西输出到屏幕上，或者通过系统调用输出。所以生存主义也是分等级的。所以你是说你甚至还没达到……
is really possible in terms of coding survivalism. Using, not debugging and just using printf is just the start. You're not even at the true level of survivalism in coding. I guess I've benefited from the things I've had to program in the past. They're really well defined interfaces and like think of every thrust algorithm. Like the post conditions are spelled out explicitly what they are so it makes it really easy to write unit tests for what you're doing. Jared, when you encounter a bug that you have to debug, is it typically a like a parallelism
在编程生存主义方面真正可能的程度。不用调试器只用printf只是个开始。你甚至还没达到编程生存主义的真正境界。我想我从过去必须编写的程序中受益匪浅。它们有定义得非常好的接口，想想每个Thrust算法。比如后置条件都明确写出来了，所以为你的工作编写单元测试非常容易。Jared，当你遇到需要调试的bug时，通常是并行方面的吗？
bug? No, it's typically a compiler bug. Those are the bugs I learned too. When you run into a bug where you have to put a printf into your program, is it usually something that's like parallel? I don't know if I would say that or not. Bugs can come from, you know, bugs can come from any reason. I will say that now that I spend most days in Rust, I don't spend any time debugging. But when I am writing, if I'm writing like MLIR code
不，通常是编译器bug。那些也是我学到的bug。当你遇到需要把printf放进程序里的bug时，通常是并行相关的吗？我不知道该怎么说。Bug可能源于……你知道，Bug可能源于任何原因。我得说，现在我大部分时间都在用Rust，我不需要花时间调试。但当我在写MLIR代码时，
and C++, the first thing I have to do is debug whatever I wrote because it's not gonna work the first time for sure. And then yeah, I do use printf. I usually use printf because when I'm debugging something it's usually something that, like if it's if it's something that's not a parallel bug it's usually pretty quick for me to get to the bottom of it. But for the most part if it's a bug it's a bug that is
和C++代码时，我首先要做的是调试我写的东西，因为它第一次肯定跑不通。然后是的，我确实用printf。我通常用printf，因为当我调试某样东西时，如果它不是并行bug，我通常很快就能查出原因。但大多数情况下，如果是个bug，那它就是因为某种竞争条件或同步问题而发生的。
happening due to some like race condition or synchronization thing. And so my process is first I run compute sanitizer or like a mem checking tool that tells me whether I'm randomly writing somewhere in memory. And if that's the case, I get to the bottom of that. And then if that isn't the case, then I usually start adding printf's to see if I've got some incorrect assumption. And if I open it up in a debugger, usually the race condition, like the timing has changed. And so it's not. Like whatever the timing condition is that caused the problem has typically gone away.
所以我的流程是先运行compute sanitizer或内存检查工具，它会告诉我是否在内存中随机写入了数据。如果是这种情况，我就能查出原因。如果不是，我通常开始添加printf来查看我是否有错误的假设。如果我用调试器打开它，通常竞争条件会导致时序发生变化。所以它不是……导致问题的时序条件通常已经消失了。
One of the first jobs I had at NVIDIA, I was working on the Optics team. So Optics is like a ray tracing framework. And so one of the first jobs I had was to sit and babysit an emulator waiting for a race condition in the chip that some ray tracing code exposed. And you just sit down there for several hours just waiting for something to happen or not. But that's what I spend a week doing. Shortly after coming to Nvidia, race conditions are tricky. I had a, I had, I had a colleague who one time I was, uh, I was at the office. It was like 7 p.m. and he's sitting across from me. And, um, he, uh and he like stands up very abruptly and I'm
我在Nvidia的第一份工作之一是在Optics团队。Optics是一个光线追踪框架。所以我的第一份工作之一就是坐着监视一个模拟器，等待芯片中被某些光线追踪代码暴露出来的竞争条件。你就在那儿坐几个小时，等着事情发生或不发生。但我花了一周时间做这个。刚来Nvidia不久，竞争条件很棘手。我有一个同事，有一次我在办公室，大概晚上7点，他坐在我对面，然后他突然站起来，我问……
like where you going? He's like I have to go like I have to go monitor this bring-up machine and some other building and I'm like well why can't you monitor it from here? And he's like you don't understand it could catch fire at any moment. So I later came to understand that when you're on bring up duty, one of the jobs is you just go and sit next to the bring up machine and there's a fire extinguisher there because it's got these giant heat sinks and fans and nobody's figured out what clock speed you can run this
你去哪儿？他说我得去监控那台在另一栋楼里的启动机器。我问为什么不能从这儿监控？他说你不明白，它随时可能着火。后来我才明白，当你负责启动任务时，工作之一就是坐在启动机器旁边，旁边放着灭火器，因为它有巨大的散热片和风扇，还没人搞清楚你能以什么时钟频率安全地运行这东西。
thing at safely at. So sometimes bad things might happen and it might overheat out how like what clock speed you can run this thing at safely yet so sometimes like bad things might happen and it might overheat and it might spark and catch on fire but we figure out all those bugs before they you know get into gamers hands yeah exactly oh all right I think that's that's all I got Connor you got anything else want to ask Jared? I mean we've kept him past 30 minutes past we said we were gonna interview him and I mean, I got my sequence question answered. I got my counting iterator question answered. I Feel like we got a lot of questions answered. I mean, we're going to have to bring you on in the future.
所以有时会发生坏事，它可能会过热……还没搞清楚你能以什么时钟频率安全地运行这东西，所以有时坏事可能会发生，它可能会过热，可能会冒火花并着火，但我们在这些bug进入玩家手中之前就解决了它们。是的，没错。好吧，我想我没别的问题了。Connor，你还有什么想问Jared的吗？我的意思是，我们已经让他超时30分钟了，我们说好要采访他的，而且我的序列问题得到了解答，我的计数迭代器问题也得到了解答。我觉得我们问了很多问题。我的意思是，以后我们还得请你来。
We talked, we alluded to if you were going to start from scratch today. And, you know, we do work in research, so you're probably working on something. And at the point in time where we're working on 2.0, not of thrust necessarily, but of your next project, we will definitely have to have you back on. Oh, but maybe that's a good thing to close with, which is Jared, do you want to, you got anything you want to plug? You want to say anything or anything about-
我们谈到了，或者说暗示了如果你今天从零开始会怎样。而且，你知道，我们从事研究工作，所以你可能正在做某事。在我们做2.0版本的时候，不一定是Thrust，而是你的下一个项目，我们肯定得请你回来。哦，也许这是一个很好的结束话题，Jared，你有什么想推广的吗？你想说点什么或者关于……
It's not that you want to plug. Do you have anything that you can plug? And if you can't plug, what's the general direction of which you are working on things? So I think I mentioned, like, I have kind of a wish list for a programming language that would make software like Thrust more, much easier to write and maintain. So I would like to try to do something in that space.
不是你想推广什么。你有什么可以推广的吗？如果不能推广，你目前工作的总体方向是什么？我想我提到过，我有一个编程语言的愿望清单，它会让像Thrust这样的软件更容易编写和维护。所以我希望能在那方面做点尝试。
And hopefully that will be successful. So I would like to try to do something in that space and Hopefully hopefully that will be successful we'll see If people interested they can just look at what's going on on my github. We're not going on there But there are Some hints there of what might be next some hints on Jared's github link in the show notes folks go and drop some stars Here's the here's the real question if I really do release this as like a two and a half hour episode You should what do I call it not do that? I mean, I shouldn't but I feel like if I if I if I titled this episode
希望这会成功。所以我希望能在那方面做点尝试，希望这会成功，我们拭目以待。如果人们感兴趣，他们可以看看我的GitHub上在发生什么。我们不去那儿，但那里有一些关于下一步可能是什么的暗示。Jared的GitHub上有暗示，链接在节目说明里，伙计们，去点个星吧。这是真正的问题，如果我真的把它发布成两个半小时的剧集，我该叫它什么？不该那样做？我的意思是，我不应该，但我觉得如果我给这集起个标题……
I mean I won't but I could title it Nvidia engineers discuss like CUDA programming Given the the zeitgeist. Do you know the term that I heard over the last week? It's called gen sanity Have you heard that? He went to Taiwan and he gave his keynote at Computech on Sunday night. And on Monday, Tuesday, all these shows were talking about Gen Sanity. Because he announced not just that we were launching our global headquarters in Taipei, but that also we opened some platform to third-party vendors or
我的意思是，我不会，但我可以把它命名为“Nvidia工程师讨论CUDA编程”。考虑到现在的时代精神，你知道我上周听到的一个词吗？叫“Gen Sanity”（生成式AI狂热）。你听过吗？他去了台湾，周日晚上在Computex上发表了主题演讲。周一、周二，所有这些节目都在谈论“Gen Sanity”。因为他不仅宣布我们在台北设立全球总部，还宣布我们向第三方供应商开放了某个平台或……
something. Yeah, NVLink. NVLink, yeah, NVLink Fusion. I'm an engineer. I don't really understand what's going on but the point is is the MSNBCs of the world and the Bloombergs of the world, they love us folks and so if we named, if we called this podcast, three Nvidia engineers discuss the parallel algorithms that power the world, it would blow up. I'm not gonna do that, but I could. Oh, we gotta ask Jared, what's your favorite algorithm? Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
是的，NVLink。NVLink，是的，NVLink Fusion。我是个工程师，我不太明白发生了什么，但重点是像MSNBC和Bloomberg这样的媒体，他们喜欢我们，伙计们。所以如果我们把这个播客命名为“三位Nvidia工程师讨论驱动世界的并行算法”，它会火起来。我不会那样做，但我可以。哦，我们得问问Jared，你最喜欢的算法是什么？哦，对，对，对。
My favorite algorithm? Yeah. Inside of Thrust and outside of Thrust, if they're a different algorithm. Metropolis, Metropolis light transport is my favorite algorithm outside of thrust. What was that? Metropolis? Metropolis light transport.
我最喜欢的算法？是的。在Thrust内部和外部，如果它们是不同的算法的话。Metropolis，Metropolis光传输是我在Thrust之外最喜欢的算法。那是什么？Metropolis？Metropolis光传输。
Metropolis light transport. That sounds like something from Altered Carbon, like the Netflix show. No, it's something from graphics, computer graphics. Is that like a global illumination thing? Yeah, it's like a global illumination thing. It applies Metropolis Hastings to light light transport light transport is just what they call Rendering fancy term for rendering you can tell you can tell someone's an old-timer at Nvidia If they don't currently work in graphics, but have like deep graphics chops
Metropolis光传输。听起来像是《碳变》里的东西，就是Netflix的那部剧。不，它是图形学里的东西，计算机图形学。那是全局光照之类的东西吗？是的，是全局光照之类的。它将Metropolis-Hastings算法应用于光传输。光传输只是他们对渲染的称呼，渲染的华丽术语。你可以看出一个人是不是Nvidia的老员工，如果他们目前不在图形部门工作，但有深厚的图形功底。
Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quality. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information.
请务必查看播客应用或ADSPthepodcast.com上的节目说明，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高质量。这是我们播客的标语。那不是标语。我们的标语是“伴随着信息碎片的混乱”。
All right. All right. All right. We should let Jared go. The green grass in the background is gone, folks. Whether this was one episode or five episodes, it started out lush and green in the background and now it is a dark sky in the background of Kansas. We appreciate Jared for taking all this time tonight to chat with us. We will definitely have you back in the future.
好了，好了，好了。我们应该让Jared走了。背景里的绿草不见了，伙计们。不管这是一集还是五集，它开始时背景是郁郁葱葱的绿色，现在是堪萨斯州背景下的黑暗天空。我们感谢Jared今晚花这么多时间与我们聊天。我们以后一定会再请你来的。
I think we got to have more Nvidia internal folks. We should get Dwayne Merrill on. We should get Chris Cech on. We should get a bunch of these folks on. We're a podcast hosted by two Nvidia engineers. We should have more Nvidia folks on. I will say very clearly that this is not a work activity This is something we do outside of work I mean, yes, I that was not clear from what I just said it should be clear now
我觉得我们得请更多Nvidia内部的人。我们应该请Dwayne Merrill，应该请Chris Cech，应该请这些人来。我们是一个由两位Nvidia工程师主持的播客。我们应该请更多Nvidia的人来。我得非常明确地说，这不是工作活动，这是我们在工作之外做的事情。我的意思是，是的，我刚才说的不够清楚，现在应该清楚了。
but the point being is we do have access to We do folks that work at Nvidia hence why Jared Let's ask you it Jared. Who should we interview next? Oh, yeah, that's a good question Ian buck Do you think Ian would come on the podcast a second question to Jared do you think you would come on the podcast? He might but he probably has some good stories. Oh, yeah so I mean if my History is correct
但重点是我们确实有渠道接触到在Nvidia工作的人，所以Jared，让我们问问你，Jared。我们下一个该采访谁？哦，对，这是个好问题。Ian Buck。你觉得Ian会来上播客吗？第二个问题问Jared，你觉得你会来上播客吗？他可能会，但他可能有一些好故事。哦，是的，所以如果我的历史没记错的话，
You did thrust? Ian Before kuda was a thing did something called brook. Yeah, right which was Basically kuda before it was kuda. I think it was quite different from before it was CUDA? I think it was quite different from the CUDA. I think it had much different programming model than CUDA does. Thank you for doing this, Jared.
你做了Thrust？Ian在CUDA出现之前做了一个叫Brook的东西。是的，没错，那基本上就是CUDA出现之前的CUDA。我觉得它和CUDA出现之前的东西很不一样？我觉得它和CUDA很不一样。我觉得它的编程模型和CUDA有很大不同。谢谢你做这些，Jared。
Thanks for having me. You're welcome. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢邀请我。不客气。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。